first to Kuwait which is holding its
second parliamentary election in a year
as it tries to resolve a long-running
political crisis the snap vote was
called by the Crown Prince last month
after he dissolved Parliament friction
between the ruling family and MPS has
caused political paralysis and stalled
reforms since 2020 the assembly has been
increasingly dominated by members
opposed to the government that's chosen
by the ruling al-sabah family the last
election in September was held after
Parliament was dissolved by Royal Decree
to end a feud between the government
nmps it delivered a mandate for change
bringing 27 new members into the
50-member house but in March this year
the Constitutional Court ruled that
decree invalid reinstating the
Parliament that was elected three years
ago then last month the Crown Prince
announced Parliament would be dissolved
against sending kuwaitis back to the
polls Al jazeera's Rob Matheson is
joining us now live from Kuwait City the
second parliamentary election in a Year
Rob what's different this time and how
much enthusiasm is there for this folks
well to a certain extent there's not a
great deal of difference in terms of the
process that the the kuwaitis are going
through to elect a new Parliament but in
terms of enthusiasm well what we're
going to be watching out for is the
level of uh turnout because that is
going to show us just how invested
kuwaitis are in this latest Trend uh of
the elections it's been interesting in
the run-up to this the polling stations
have been open for the last five hours
we've seen a steady stream of ladies
coming through to cast their ballots
they're doing this in a school queue
they're a separate uh polling stations
from men and women scattered across
Kuwait but the turnout is going to be
key there are 700 and 793
000 registered voters in Kuwait that's
out of a population of about a million
but in the run-up to this election the
local media was suggesting the turnout
could be anything between about 50 to 60
percent now in a lot of the elections
that Al Jazeera covers 50 to 60 percent
turnout would actually be pretty good
but for Kuwait that's not great and that
is an indication perhaps of the level of
dissatisfaction that a lot of people are
feeling about the politics at the moment
it's interesting because politics is
very much a talking point in Kuwait and
unfortunately for the last two and a
half years it's been the talking point
for all the wrong reasons some of which
you've just mentioned now to talk to me
about this I've got lyanna our Wadi she
is the co-founder of modawi's listen it
is an organization dedicated to
supporting women who want to become
elected into positions in politics and
local Politics as well as social
organizations thank you very much indeed
for being with us how optimistic should
kuwaitis be that this Parliament this
coming Parliament could be any different
to the ones that we've seen before I
think it would be an unfair comparison
to compare their past Parliament to this
new upcoming one since it lasted for
around five months where it didn't give
candidates enough time to kind of like
see their process so instead I wouldn't
say that we should be optimistic I would
say that perhaps weighted escalators
should be looking forward to you know
slightly changing and you know and
moving towards progressiveness given
that we're a young democracy and
democracy is take time to change
people's voting behavior yes the
Democracy came about because the the
Constitution that came in in 1962 and we
forget that that is actually
comparatively recently compared to to
many uh democracies looking ahead do you
think that this is essentially a
teething problem on the road to wider
democracy in Kuwait I
organization specializes in as I
mentioned supporting women who want to
get elected into various organizations
including politics
confident can women be that the
Parliament that is going to come in is
going to be able to serve their needs
that they're going to be represented in
a way that they believe they should yes
not so confident to that extent if we're
looking forward towards for a parliament
that will actually represent us Kuwaiti
women and our needs not so optimistic we
don't have enough women running for
elected office positions in Kuwait the
majority of the population keeps on
judging you know very few candidates
that made it to Parliament and their
performance that's a very unfair
comparison I believe so there is still a
need to raise more awareness and
normalize having women in elected office
positions in Kuwait that is still it can
be seen by taboo by a lot of the
population
thank you very much indeed for talking
to us thank you well the results are
going to start coming in when the polls
close tonight at eight o'clock local
time that's about 17 GMT but it's going
to take a long time to pull together an
analysis of what the parliament is going
to look like because we are looking at
50 independent people who are sitting in
the elected uh it's in those elected
seats so it's likely that we're probably
not going to get a clearer result until
Wednesday Al Jazeera of course is going
to be here to be covering that and
trying to get a sense of what is
happening what the new Parliament is
going to mean we will of course be
checking in with you throughout the day
Rob Matheson in Kuwait City thank you
very much